[Music]
this living cultural landscape is
nestled into the remote slopes of the
chordal Yarra mountain range in the
Philippines
[Music]
for two thousand years the mountains of
fu Gao province have been cultivated
with terrorist rice fields that
stretched thousands of feet high
[Music]
they serve as an example of sustainable
agriculture with traditional techniques
these emeralds fields and the knowledge
to farm them have been passed down from
generation to generation for centuries
they've long been central to the
survival of the e foo cow people and
they also hold great cultural
significance entire communities
cooperate on seasonal systems of
planting pest control and harvest
these coordinated efforts are tied to
lunar cycles and sometimes accompanied
by religious rituals the UNESCO site
encompasses five different clusters of
rice terraces in the area the banal a
rice terraces are the most famous of the
lot the now way is about 230 miles north
of Manila and buses depart daily from
the capital it can take up to 10 hours
to drive up the mountainous terrain to
the rice fields
[Music]
if you take a guided hiking tour make
sure to pack a picnic for an outstanding
view of this remarkable landscape
[Music]
you
[Music]